I'm joined now by our senior
correspondent David Bowden and David
what more do we know about what is
happening in Munich well this is a place
called the Olympia shopping center it is
in the north of Munich I'm told and this
is unfolding pretty much as we speak
they are clearing the shopping center
but there are reports that 15 people may
have been shot
now whether one or more of them has been
fatally wounded we do not know clearly
the shopping center has been evacuated
the person that is shooting this it's a
man is clearly outside and I've been
watching for a few minutes before I came
on here he's been outside all the time
so he will be getting second third and
rumor mill of what's happening inside
but you can see emergency service
vehicles clearly well across this now
and presumably if a gun man the gun
person will hopefully be being contained
by them at the moment but we've got no
idea whether this is an incident that is
effectively over and that this person
has shot as many people as he or she
intended to do and has now either
disappeared or has been neutralized in
that term that security forces tend to
use by the officials of the authorities
there or not so this may be an ongoing
situation that's unfolding and we can't
see what's happening inside or it may
have happened it may effectively be over
and now people are dealing with the
aftermath it's simply too early to tell
exactly what is going on but you can see
the shopping center it's called the
Olympia shopping center it's in the
north of Munich but clearly these people
who are outside either do not feel that
they're threatened in any way or the
emergency services who are clearly on
hand have decided that that is a safe
distance we don't have any of those
pictures that we've seen so recently of
people just charging down streets to get
away from the vicinity whatever has
happened has happened inside and appears
to be contained inside